imagine you're in a situation where you
have a compromise femoral artery you're
bleeding out and you're waiting for the
first responder who has an average
response time of 12 minutes in most
areas in the country and you bleed out
in three a 29 piece of equipment and a
little bit of training that you could
literally get from YouTube could save
your life why would you not pay
attention to that
what's your background why should anyone
listen to you about how to be prepared
for anything
yeah I I think mostly my background is
in the military
and the CIA that's what kind of I'm I'm
known for but I don't think that's why I
am the expert at preparedness I think
kind of as a leader and as somebody
who's managed a lot of people in the
military
I know how to connect people who are
assets subject matter experts with
people who are trying to get information
to make themselves better so that's kind
of how I came to the conclusion that
um civilians needed preparedness in
their life so nothing complex I think my
field of experience is very narrow very
specific and and its totality has a lot
to do with preparedness but not
specifically you need experts in all the
fields which I am not an expert in I'm
just a collaborator I'm the conduit
between experts and you and people I
call it podcast smarts so it's the it's
the level of knowledge that I've got on
most topics like I don't actually know
it inside out I know enough to be able
to have a podcast about it and to hold a
conversation but if you want to go out
and do it if you want if you want to go
build a bridge you can't speak to me I
can have a conversation with you about a
bridge builder I once spoke to but like
you need to find the man that builds the
bridges and then you can speak to him
about how to build a bridge so yeah I
think um podcast smarts or preparedness
smarts perhaps is is a good uh a good
way to look at it one of the questions I
had I actually asked
um Sean Ryan this and Andy Stumpf why do
you think it is that
members of the CIA people who are
working for the CIA are seen in such a
different light to people who are in the
Special Forces especially given that
there is quite a regular conveyor belt
of Special Forces to CIA
um it just seems to me that there's a
branding or a marketing problem with
regards to how the operatives working in
three-letter agencies are perceived by
The Wider public
yeah I think it's a lot to do with the
idea of Cloak and Dagger and you know
operating with certain privileges
and all the things behind the curtain
you know I I had an idea
until I started working with the CIA and
I'm like oh they're just like me you
know super intelligent highly capable
human beings with endless budgets but I
think a lot of the perception is based
in the uh
I don't know I think it's based in
fantasy it's based in Hollywood it's
based in books that I grew up reading on
the office of strategic services in the
CIA and so I think that's a good thing
partly for the culture
um but I have seen it be the bad thing
in many instances because you know I've
I've rolled with case officers who
thought they were Jason Bourne and I'm
like no no no no you're not Jason Bourne
you're capable you're a case officer
you're intelligent but you're not Jason
Bourne that doesn't exist and so I I
think that helps with recruitment it's
like kind of like the BUDs program for
the Navy it's a genius marketing tactic
why because everybody wants to be a seal
and then when you go in and the Navy
knows 99 of everybody who comes in is
going to wash out well then you have the
needs of the Navy you could fill the
ranks and fill the positions that nobody
else wants to do
um with a very smart and sound marketing
tactic
um so I think part of that is is the
reason why I wanted to be in the CIA
um but I think that's for a reason
specific reason
speaking of Jason Bourne you were
briefly labeled as a domestic terrorist
weren't you
I was I was um I was in my organization
called American contingency was
identified as a militant violent
extremist organization
and they didn't say I actually was an
mve
they said I was capable as an
organization uh as a pass-through entity
of potentially
you know
recruiting and facilitating domestic
terrorists who wanted to use our
platform
um as a place to hang out and I think
that's any place to hang out I mean
certainly there are social media
platforms where people do things like
that but mine was
um personally identifying me as the
potential problem because my background
which is ironic right you're a Green
Beret you're a CIA guy you do all the
service you do all the selfless service
and sacrifice I'm thinking you're doing
it for the for the good and then on the
tail end of that you're kind of seen as
the bad guy I I think it's a natural
storyline that uh was bound to happen to
everybody especially somebody coming out
you know like Sean Ryan in any stump
talking about their experiences from
those organizations I'm not surprised it
sucks but I'm not surprised yeah is it
is it almost like the
government getting concerned at someone
being a little bit too independent
that's what it feels like a little bit
to me like
you know we want whatever it is a
well-armed uh populist or whatever it
says in the Declaration of Independence
that you guys have got it's like but not
that competent like well-armed but
incompetent or like not sufficiently
well sophisticated and yeah if you've
got yourself to the stage where you guys
can
you know basically rally together a
pretty competent Army
that's the sort of thing that might be
seen as a threat yeah I think any time
you take ownership of anything
then you're a threat to some other
institution business entity because
you're taking that Independence and
you're disaffecting somebody else's
Independence uh you would have
previously been reliant on them 100 and
so if if the idea in a government is
um you're not empowering the people but
you're providing them services that
they're dependent on and you're
centralizing everything when those
people try to decentralize and take back
their self-reliance
um that messes the system up I mean it's
like the idea of like
um going out and finding
um natural medicinal means to make your
health and wellness better like if you
do that well you're potentially in
trolls
you know moving in an audience moving a
market you're disaffecting big Pharma
and that's not a good thing so if I'm
working like a business I'm looking for
marketing tactics to counter and debate
all the things that you're doing in fact
I'll go out of my way to suppressed and
shut you down so we advocate for
self-reliance and taking back that
Reliance in your life that you normally
Outsource to institutions
um because the efficiency and the
optimization that you bought into isn't
necessarily beneficial nowadays and and
I think that's that's across the board
that's insecurity that's in health care
that's in education and so I want people
to take that back and that's a threat to
somebody out there
okay so justify to me British person
right who comes from a country that
doesn't have the same types of risks
perhaps that are over here in terms of
weather uh in terms of firearms in term
terms of the mental health of some of
the homeless people that exist there are
a number of big differences despite the
fact that we speak the same language
why is
preparedness such a huge risk why is the
lack of preparedness such a huge risk do
we not have institutions that can
already step in we've got hospitals
we've got police officers we've got
supermarkets like
what's the case for preparedness
yeah it's a very interesting one we get
asked a lot of that kind of question
depending on the country and the place
in the world and I just did a book deal
with some European countries of selling
that book overseas uh the book I wrote
prepared and and that's very interesting
but all we have to do is go back just a
little bit in time to 1941 the beginning
of World War II and when we look at what
was going on in the country there were
superpowers there were countries that
were accumulating Power by
disenfranchising and suppressing and
oppressing people around them and they
were doing so behind a veil you know
there wasn't a lot of advertisement of
these things that were going on you
don't typically show your hand and then
all of a sudden they were taking over
countries I mean the United Kingdom
British uh the British were being
bombarded by Nazi Germany and that
didn't take a lot of moves to get to
catastrophic circumstances where it was
too late in a modern society just look
back a year and some change when we
thought this could never happen to
anybody in modern civilization and
Ukrainian officials are handing out
AK-47s and rifles to middle-aged males
that were willing to fight for their
country because they didn't have the
power the government the institution had
the power and there was an agreement
sovereignty wise that the government was
going to be able to take care of the
people but they can't when a superpower
decides I'm just going to go into your
country and just take it over and that
would never happen and it just happened
name that with the things that took
place in this
um in this world over the last few years
including the pandemic and you realize
that a lot of the bargaining
the agreements the protocols and the
institutions that we established was all
about efficiency and there was there was
a unspoken agreement that I was going to
pay taxes and all these institutions
around me were going to handle
everything well that's the case until
it's not and when it's not as an
individual what are you able to do to
take care of your family so at a high
level yeah preparedness is important for
communities cultures countries but at a
very low level
independently there's things that you
need to be able to do and not so
catastrophic circumstances not talking
about the world war I'm talking about
the supply chain breaks I'm talking
about the natural disaster hits are you
able at the Tactical level as I would
describe it in the military are you able
to take care of your own if you can't
take care of your own and you have to
wait for the institution to take care of
you that's a problem because you know
all it takes is a couple of those things
to happen and then to converge and like
Malcolm Gladwell said there will be a
Tipping Point and it typically All Rolls
downhill after that so I think
preparedness is important
um at the very visceral connected level
with human beings day to day
and at the higher levels for countries
and you know European unions and
collectives to think about it as well
it's a nice
uh
reminder I think as much as the war in
Ukraine doesn't need to it probably
didn't need to happen in order to be a
symbolic reminder for everybody it is
one that for people to think ah you know
1941 London uh we're an ascended species
now we're beyond that this isn't
anything that we need to be concerned
about yo you do you do there's there are
still scenarios I I tweeted something
the other day this is what Andy taught
me about um 76 of 18 to 24 year old
American men would be ineligible to
serve uh in the armed forces because of
health or criminal record problems that
obesity and other sort of Health
complications and um I quote tweeted it
saying America's if there's a
land Invasion and I got a bunch of
responses in the replies explaining why
America would be really hard to invade
by land and I was like that's not the
lesson to take away from this issue like
the lessons take away from this issue is
that you have a very unready populace
not that ah yeah but there's lots of
water in between us and Japan ah yeah
but you know Russia wouldn't be able to
sneak around the the top of Greenland ah
yeah but you know there's mountains in
the middle of the country yeah sure like
that's
that's correct but relying on structure
as opposed to relying on capability
seems like a weakness
yeah completely and I you know that
statistic relates to body mass index and
lack of upper body strength I mean when
a benefit a proxy benefit of freedom is
convenience the problem with convenience
is sometimes it gets so convenient
you're complacent and that complacency
leads to risk right and it happens it's
kind of like the first it's like the
full circle of life where you have it
all until things are so good then
something's bound to break and then you
kind of reset Everything full circle and
I think that's where we're at as a
society we have it so good and we we
have it so good we manufacture things
that we think are bad and that's a first
world problem it's like the rest of the
world's problem which are very real
problems that have to do with the
hierarchy of needs and survival like the
lack of food like a lack of basic health
care
um the lack of medicine to treat disease
these things are real problems we we are
manufacturing things and when you look
at Readiness when you look at capability
that is the lack of preparedness I feel
like with me and Andy with me and Sean
the guys that I know that I grew up with
in the military that are kind of doing
what we do generally speaking we're all
doing the same thing we're trying to
build resilience back into the
population whether that's through
education through experiences through
podcast whatever it may be it's about
building resilience back in this country
because we feel every single day that
it's slipping away
everyone will immediately think when you
talk about preparedness about guns and
food that was where my mind went to
right so what particular specific type
of everyday carry weapon with which
particular site and which particular
ammunitions and how many kilos of rice
do I need that's the first place that
everyone goes to but I think you make a
really good point that there are
elements of mindset that people need to
build as a foundation before you think
about any of that stuff
yeah it's important and I knew that was
going to happen
it's a stereotype I've been fighting
uphill in a battle since the beginning
of field crafts survival my company
because
um let's be honest like a prepper the
tinfoil hat guy living in a aluminum RV
in the middle of Arizona
um who's preparing for the apocalypse
um is not a good representation of what
we're talking about and you know I I
talk about catastrophe and even in the
front of my book it says a manual for
surviving worst case scenarios but worst
case is it necessarily the zombie
apocalypse worst case could be the
accident it could be the trauma that you
experience and it certainly could be
scaled it could be the worst worst thing
but our ability kind of as a as a
species as a as an American citizen to
recognize what our worst day is I mean
we see guys going into fight or flight
smashing their head on the steering
wheel
um completely losing yet emotionally
because we don't have a good Baseline of
resilience built in our culture and it's
kind of slipping away and what do you
need to repair that well you need
hardship but how much hardship do we
have living in climate controlled
um boxes we drive in a box that's
climate control we walk 10 feet through
125 degree heat index index in Texas and
we're back into another climate control
box so we are certainly going through
the the Comfort crisis
um and I think that resilience is very
important to build back in because it's
not about the EDC pistol it's those are
statistical improbabilities
if you look at statistical probabilities
all the statistics that I see in mental
health decline
I associate drug overdose with fentanyl
I mean that's that's a hundred thousand
Americans likely to be the leading cause
of death in men if not already this year
on track for that when I see violence
Spike murder rates Spike I think that is
a
a demonstration of the lack of
resilience we have in our communities
and in our people and and that's a
problem and and I hope the book as
positioned re-educates people on that
um but certainly The Stereotype is
something that I'm going to continue to
fight uphill so talk to me the about the
biggest risks statistically that people
don't think about something tells me uh
for instance terrorism is covered in the
newspapers it's like 25 I think of
headline stories about threats and yet
heart disease kills 60 of people so
there is a disparity between what people
expect and what reality is actually
going to provide them as a risk what are
the biggest risks statistically that
people aren't thinking about
yeah that's a very um interesting
question because you're absolutely right
the national media and the headlines
will kind of determine the messaging and
how we're manipulated to understand the
world around us so if you're watching
social media and you're seeing the world
burn down you feel that way until you go
outside and you realize that's not the
specific case but in some places as a
statistical probability uh for example
drug overdoses are at a record high a
great example of San Francisco you know
I I criticize Gavin Newsom because he
seems very arrogant in the position that
he is as a politician bragging about the
status of his state California which I
was born in I actually started philcrowd
survival in California and moved out
when I saw it falling apart the
statistic is in May you know a month ago
74 people died on the Streets of San
Francisco in one city yes heavy
population but 74 people died of drug
overdoses 69 out of those 74 actually
died from fentanyl specifically I think
fit and Fentanyl overdoses are a direct
um attack on our security I think it's a
national security threat because if you
track it and trace it it's coming from
China being shipped to Mexico and being
brought in by the cartels that is
definitely a national security risk when
you're looking at a hundred thousand
Americans that are dying now you take 74
just as a number and you compare it to
mass killings mass killings the
estimates are between 85 and 95
casualties of mass killings which is
four or more deaths in a mass killing so
if you hit the net National media
headline news you would think
systemically there is a cancer of mass
killings taking place all across this
country from January until now there's
been 85 total deaths in one month in one
city because of drug overdoses which I
think is a mental health issue along
with homelessness and all the things
that are combined a recipe for disaster
there's been nearly the same number and
one void of that and so I look at
statistics and it's very important to
highlight them because it's facts now
when we're weighing statistics compared
um or comparing our lives and our daily
routines to the world around us what's
likely going to kill you well it's not
going to be the self-defense gunfight or
the mass killing period it's not even
going to be the drug overdose it's
likely to be the vehicle accident right
40 000 Americans die every single year
and vehicle accidents more important in
the statistic is two million people are
injured out of this six million
accidents that takes place in vehicles
across the country but how many people
are on their cell phone putting their
makeup and eating a Subway sandwich at
the same time while driving their
vehicles completely at the loss of focus
I mean we're automating vehicles to
drive for us so we could do those things
now lastly let's set aside that
statistic at forty thousand you have a
statistic of gun deaths in this country
and it's around 60 plus thousand
depending on the institution and the way
they've measured the stats but 60 000
Americans per year and you would go oh
well Mike I told you so because sixty
thousand Americans die from Guns except
the missing point in the statistic is 60
of that is from suicide so now if we
weigh all the risk and the world around
us what's most likely to kill us is the
lack of resilience and the breakdown of
our mental health because all of that
leads to I don't know binge eating which
is the number one cause of death and
cardiovascular disease so we have to pay
attention to it all it can be
overwhelming but it like how I try to
outline in the book is like I want
people to think about probabilities to
think about things that are likely to
happen to them if you're in Florida
focused on an earthquake if you're in
California focused on a a you know a cat
5 hurricane then you're thinking about
your environment wrong all those factors
matter and the statistics matter the
most you mentioned car accident that as
probably one of the most common most
likely high risk scenarios that an
everyday person is going to get
themselves into and this is a crow it
doesn't matter which country you're in
right I mean uh America does have some
very bad drivers in it the the driving
test is not sufficiently rigorous over
here
um but what are the fundamentals let's
say that I mean paying attention to the
road not using your phone while you
drive not trying to put your makeup on
or eat a Subway sandwich whilst texting
probably to get started
but what else let's say that it is you
wake up this morning and without knowing
it today is the worst day of your life
on the road
what are the things that people need to
be aware of the most common errors that
they make in terms of preparedness
mindset and everything else yeah there's
there's two specific ones that come to
mind one is situation awareness we have
a complete loss of situation awareness
in the world around us because we are
immersed in our phones I mean a shocking
statistic is
um teenage girls spend anywhere from
three and a half to seven hours a day on
social media and that is a scary
statistic with that I believe 53 of them
claiming to be anxious depressed and
having suicidal ideation that's scary so
we set that aside situation awareness
and not paying attention is killing
people the most I mean texting
especially on your phone is going to
kill you the most so when you're paying
attention because the phone is down and
you create a rule you're like hey if
we're in this vehicle we're not watching
TV we're not watching YouTube while
we're driving we're not doing
distractive things we're putting the
phone down and we're just on driving
when I used to drive in Libya I spent
nearly a year in Libya fascinating
country at the the top of Africa and if
you called a Libyan and African they
would scold you to death because they
don't think they're Africans they think
they're Arabs which they distinctly are
and in that culture
if you drive to an intersection there
likely is no lights and there's a right
of way it happens to be to the right
like the people to the right of you have
the right of way if they arrive it's not
who arrives first it's the people to the
right
Most Fascinating if you're driving next
to somebody
um and you look over to the right and
they're an inch ahead of you then they
have the right away so if they decide to
Veer into your lane you have the
obligation to slow down stop and avoid
contact they don't have an obligation to
even look in their blind spot by looking
over their shoulder and the reason
that's fascinating is because there's
not a lot of vehicle accidents in Libya
I mean I would drive from the state
department from the embassy to my base
of operations where I was running a
counterterrorism program at the time and
it would be a 30-minute Drive I would
never see an accident take that same
thing when I was stationed at Fort
Carson when I was driving from Monument
Colorado to Fort Carson Colorado a same
30-minute commute if there was inclement
weather there was any kind of change in
the pattern you would see distinctly
three four five ten vehicle accidents
depending on the severity the other part
of that is most people die in vehicle
accidents when they over were correct
because like you said we don't have a
protocol for teaching Defensive Driving
we're more focused on parallel parking
as a check the block prerequisite for
driving then we are actually handling
the vehicle and understanding how it
works so if you go off the right side of
the road and you lose traction the over
correction which is a reaction that's
natural to jerk the steering wheel the
opposite direction you think would
self-correct you except you don't have
traction you have a loss of traction so
then when you over correct the steering
wheel and you come back on the road
immediately you gain traction which
slingshots you into oncoming traffic
causing head-on collisions that's the
leading cause of death in the mistake so
how do we fix that well we talk about it
we understand it we implement it in the
training and then we have people go
through extra training like defensive
driving training and that one little
step by identifying like hey people are
dying here what should we do here that
one little fix could save thousands of
lives but again we've outsourced the
institution and go they need to be
responsible for it well they're not
going to fix it and if we identify that
then we could fix it ourselves because
we have this thing called free will just
do it yourself and a lot of these things
that I talk about their nuances and a
lot of people they hear it and they go
oh yeah whatever well it doesn't matter
to you until your child your loved one
gets in that vehicle accident you go it
was so preventable it was something so
simple if we just paid attention and
just put a little effort we could have
avoided that mistake that led to death
or injury what should everybody have in
the car in terms of uh tactical
preparedness
yeah that's an easy one for me I I and I
I do derive this from my experience me
and Sean Ryan work together in the same
office and when we were downrange
together
um which is kind of similar in a
semi-permissive environment to America
right you're you're in a a decent place
you know going about your business and
everything's cool until it's not and so
you have to be prepared the first thing
I would recommend is a mobile trauma kit
or vehicle trauma kit which is basically
a first aid kit meant to address the
things that you would experience in a
vehicle like if you have Band-Aids and
bassetration in your vehicle yeah sure
but that's more likely to be used in a
first aid kit on a hike if you're in
your vehicle you likely need burn
bandages because if you put gauze on a
burn from an accident and you treat
yourself that way not understanding how
to do it you're causing infection you're
causing issues so I think all these
things are important first aid is the
start point to that especially for
stopping the bleed that's a basic
tourniquet we recommend any in aemt
certified tourniquet tacmed Solutions uh
Softee wide North American rescues cat 7
tourniquet these are certified tested
evaluated in combat to stop the bleed
and we tell people like yeah a lot of
people don't think about this and they
don't want to put the effort in it but
imagine you're in a situation where you
have a compromise femoral artery you're
bleeding out and you're waiting for the
first responder who has an average
response time of 12 minutes in most
areas in the country and you bleed out
in three a 29 piece of equipment and a
little bit of training that you could
literally get from YouTube from
fieldcraft survival's YouTube channel
could save your life why would you not
pay attention to that lastly I would say
survival and maintenance are equally as
important I mean a 22 year old girl died
in Buffalo New York with 17 other
innocent people who got stuck in a
snowstorm she died in her vehicle six
minutes from her home she literally
could see doors of houses but she called
her family FaceTime them and said hey
I'm stuck in this snowstorm I don't know
what to do and she stayed in the vehicle
the exhaust got covered with snow it
blocked it out the carbon monoxide went
up into the vehicle and she died it's
like what a what a senseless death with
a little bit of Education have the tools
and survival and maintenance and
Recovery that you're going to need in
the worst case scenario mylar space
spank it a wool blanket hell a sleeping
bag in the back of the trunk if you have
the capacity if you have the space you
might as well have the equipment and the
training as well I remember talking to
Tim Kennedy about this and he was saying
he couldn't believe how many Americans
don't know how to drive stick
now in the UK that's very very common
and he used this example of saying okay
so you and your kids are away on some
lovely holiday up in the mountains
somewhere and the car breaks down
and the only vehicle that is left to
drive home is one that isn't an
automatic and you've got a bunch of
different families together and maybe
somebody's injured and you need to go
and get things and you need to bring
them back and you need to get people
away to the hospital
and you don't know how to drive a manual
car
yeah I I think immediately about
um you know this this idea of
Outsourcing the institutions the reason
we did we do that is because we get back
time right time is one of our greatest
resources and when you get that time
back how about you're reallocate it into
going to sheepdog response go into
fieldcraft survive going anywhere go to
your local Driving Academy and learn to
get those hard skills that are so
important in this type of World
um I mean with that same example think
about the people who can't change the
tire on their vehicle they don't know
where their spare tire is at they they
don't know where
um you know they they know the button
they got to push they know the phone
number they have to call to get Triple A
out to their location and they would
rather wait for six hours on the side of
the highway than take the 10 minutes to
learn and literally change a tire on the
side of the highway and and look it's
not a man skill these are like people
skills like if you don't have these
basic skill sets these hard skills in
the education man you're setting
yourself up for disaster and that that's
what that's what I'm like fearful of the
most which is what motivates me every
single day because I'm like people don't
understand the basics and when we start
getting the affirmation or the feedback
of saying hey I took that tourniquet
class it took me five minutes and it
saved my life for somebody I Love's life
it's like man it's so simple we just
need to get back to basics thinking
about mindset again as well how can
people learn to eliminate the freeze
response
yeah it's a big one there's two
components of freeze the first component
of freeze that we typically understand
is fight flight or freeze it has to do
with a sympathetic nervous response
which is a basic
um mechanism of survival it's actually
the mobilization tactic for survival
right your central nervous system
activates your physical body so you
could survive the the leopard attack
right that's one component because we
freeze as an advantage of
maintaining surreptitious movement to
not be discovered by the Predator as we
are the prey and we continue to move
the most important thing that I've
discovered I I actually first discovered
this from Amanda Ripley from her book
Unthinkable which man I'd love to talk
you should you should podcast Amanda
Ripley she's that book's amazing
Unthinkable and when when you hear about
the story from the Virginia Tech
shooting she talks about this mechanism
of freeze that is a actual
parasympathetic phase so arrest and
digest we go to fight or flight and then
it's hypo arousal where hyper arousal is
the spike in the curve then on the back
side of it you have hypoarousal where
we're frozen solid it's like the same
things possums do where they pretend the
Fate their death why because I mean it's
a smart tactic in the animal kingdom
like if I'm dead or if I look like I'm
dead I mean a possum actually secretes a
foul smelling odor which is gross and I
don't recommend people poop on
themselves but it's like that's a good
tactic so in Virginia Tech the shooter
goes into a a classroom after murdering
multiple people in other classrooms a
total of 33 innocent lives taken that
day when he goes into the classroom he
shoots every single person in that
classroom except for the student who put
himself in a contorted position and
fainted his own uh death he pretended to
be dead he doesn't even know why he did
that he actually said
the only thing he thought was if I
pretend like I'm dead I maybe he'll
bypass me and he did the fascinating
thing is when he tried to move
when he tried to get himself up
he couldn't fill his legs and he
actually had the thought getting shot
isn't that that isn't that that bad it
doesn't hurt that bad but he hadn't been
shot well one he had disassociated the
actual experience because that's what
you do under uh intense trauma it's
recognized in sexual assault victims
um it's recognizing children who were
assaulted and he couldn't fill his legs
because natural opiates were transferred
into his body some scientists believed
to make the transition from life to
death a little bit easier which I find
fascinating but that mechanism of freeze
exists in you and I tell people like
if you train if you educate yourself you
have all the tools what you might not
understand is under stress the
suppression of it you might activate a
trigger it might even be a memory that's
faint in your mind or that you haven't
even recalled that activates this freeze
response and freezes you up where you
can't move and that isn't necessarily a
good thing at Virginia Tech it worked
out for him but in a situation where you
need your hands you need Mobility it
actually might set you up for failure so
both mechanisms of freeze are important
to understand
because the more you understand it the
more you could understand the symptoms
as they take place like the sweating
Palm like you know the heart rate
accelerating and you can control those
things before it happens
Andy Stumpf told me about a
um it may have been sheepdog response or
it may be one of the things that he's
involved in and they're using simunition
rounds and I think that there is a a
person being belligerent as you are
supposedly walking back to the car from
a supermarket and this person comes
towards you and you're told everybody's
watching and you're told these are the
things you need to decide if you're
going to pull the trigger when to pull
the trigger and he was like the number
of people who are going to life are
going to prison for life for murder in
that scenario is huge that this is
simunition rounds everybody is aware
that they probably should be owing on
the side of caution because they're
literally being observed by people that
are going to judge them for this and as
soon as a bit of pressure gets deployed
the decision-making criteria begins to
fall apart people's ability to be
rational their ability to be calm
um it just falls out of the window and
he's like you're you're going to jail
you're going to go to jail for the rest
of your life
for that for that scenario it's crazy
yeah that that course is actually uh
from my company's training called
personal security which is a simulation
based uh self-defense course and it's
fascinating I mean it's the most
fascinating thing that I think
um most tactical or self-defense
trainers don't focus on like everybody
wants to focus on the Nuance of shooting
the gun into the paper to the steel
because that dopamine you get from the
gun exploding in your hands feels good
it's like oh that was fun there was
exhilaration but those endorphins that
were released in that experience have
nothing to do with the actual events
that are going to take place suppressed
under stress and what we find and Andy
stump teaches this class with me what we
find always is the people who train
literally the most in the technical
skill set the specific thing when put
under stress go high and right which is
just an example of them going extreme
and and you go wait so you just killed
this guy and then open parking lot and
why did you do that well he was going
after my wife yeah but he was lunging at
your wife but he didn't have a weapon he
didn't say he was going to harm her he
said he actually wanted food or money
and you shot him in the back five times
this has literally happened in her
course and it's like and these guys are
like yeah but that's what you do right
it's like no no no no no and then you
look at the students you say who here
would put him in prison for the rest of
his life and everybody raises their hand
there's there's not even a question so
the the question for people is yes hard
skills are important to train but have
you took those technical skills and
exercised them in the culmination of
stress because that's what disaster is
so you have to be able to make rapid
decision making in real time it's why I
am highly critical of guys running and
gutting on flat ranges as an exercise
and demonstrating their tactical
capability that's not even what it's
about that's choreographed what's
important is taking those technical
skills and knowing how to discriminate
friend from foe knowing when to make a
rational legal and just decision under
stress in a millisecond it it's
fascinating it's one of my favorite
parts of training but it's the most
important thing that we do is culminate
and inoculate civilians under stress to
make them understand why it's so
important we do it all the time but it's
so important what do people not
understand about reasonable Force about
the use of firearms about when you can
and can't deploy them appropriately the
the biggest factor is their their
personal decision point I mean I I do a
scenario where I I stand everybody up
and we walk through a narration of a
situation where somebody's entering
their house and and you'll never believe
like the extremes that we get where it's
like the person walks in and then
somebody sits down which represents them
hey I shot the guy and then the scenario
continues and the person shot the guy as
he came in the door and there's a whole
bunch of people still standing then a
whole bunch of people sit down through
the scenario and at the very end I'm
like the the guy has a gun pointed to
your loved one's head and he's prepping
the trigger and the person still hasn't
sat down so in our culture depending on
your background your experiences your
training where you come from really
establishes your criteria for using
deadly force so if you say to the normal
people when would you use deadly force
they'll typically give you the legal
jargon well I would use deadly force
when my life is in Jeopardy or comprom
and I'm like no no no that's from the
concealed carry handbook I'm saying when
would you actually use deadly force and
and we talk through it right we war game
it we do course of action development
and that's the point because when you
start doing that with that q a session
with the student they realize very
quickly they've never thought about it
but you're on the Range on the weekend
shooting the human target that
represents a bad guy but you never
thought about the criteria and the
decision that you morally and ethically
and legally can shoot somebody and and
that's the disparity the breakdown in
the whole chain is like we're we're you
know we're trying to build the cart
before we even thought about the horse
like you need to do both simultaneously
uh and I think
history now is showing us across the
country that even when you think you
have the right intent moral
justification legal justification that
there's a potential of a D.A who has a
skewed perspective of self-defense
bringing in a jury of not your peers
because they don't think like you and
then convicting you of murder it just
happened in Texas and it's likely going
to happen uh to this Mr Penny former
Marine who winded up killed in uh
accidentally killed and Jordan Italy
um this Michael Jackson impersonator
what was the story in Texas
the story in Texas was there was a
protest and this guy was in the Army he
was part-time Uber driving and he
dropped off his customer in the middle
of this protest which bad move anyway he
gets surrounded and kind of gets locked
into position he's got a pistol and a
one of the protesters has an AK-47 walks
up to the vehicle and he uses deadly
force his justification was the guy
raised the gun towards him there's video
evidence that shows the the gun aligned
but not him raising it and and but
there's also a post of him saying if
that ever happened to me if I ever got
grid locked in I I would I would show
these people what's up you know I'm
paraphrasing here but essentially when
you take all the evidence in totality
seemingly the jury is like he wanted to
get into the fight
he knew what he was doing deliberately
and he took somebody's life but I'm like
he's in a castle doctrine state of stand
your ground in Texas which has some of
the most lenient self-defense laws in
the country and he's in a vehicle
um protecting his life seemingly against
a man with an AK-47
um he said he didn't have one in the
chamber One in the Chamber or not it's
like wow that's clear-cut case of
self-defense he wasn't he wasn't
carrying Israeli this doesn't we don't
need to be too concerned about that
exactly so it's like clear-cut case but
not so clear-cut when he's got convicted
of 25 years in prison which is crazy
well this is one of the things man like
I I don't really understand I'd love to
get a legal expert on to explain this
but it seems like over time
by the nature of
precedence being set which inevitably
encroach and create holes in what are
much more smooth understandings of what
the law is it seems to me like almost
like the law of entropy that over time
laws are inevitably going to become more
and more messy because you have more and
more precedence that allow you to either
be convicted or let off based on one or
another previous historical case
yeah the the precedent that's being set
now is unprecedented right I mean the
the legal justification
um for convicting some of these people
who by the way there are a lot of states
that have Good Samaritan laws like if
you bypass somebody in need
um you'll get convicted but they're not
leaning so heavy on Prosecuting people
who are bypassing other human beings but
they're heavily politically messaging
that if you get involved because you're
a vigilante I mean Daniel penny is
considered a vigilante and all the
circumstances in the lead up at least
from the evidence that I've analyzed of
The Facts of the case
it's like man this guy was just trying
to do good by protecting people around
him and yeah tragically this man passed
away but this guy wasn't innocent so
it's very complicated but that precedent
leaning forward especially in those
States and those cities those towns is
scary because there's a breakdown in the
institution right the breakdown is well
why didn't the police get involved I
mean this guy was arrested 44 times as
Jordan guy and it's like well why didn't
they protect the people well it's so
political they want to get involved
because there's so much liability so
it's like you're damned if you do you're
damned if you're don't and so it's like
just stay at home and lock yourself
behind a closed door and you won't ever
have to worry about it but it's like who
wants to live that way there's an
interesting
um
Trend that I noticed since moving to
Texas among some of the guys that are
very very competent with firearms and
um I think you mentioned it before that
there are some people and I noticed this
among some of the guys that I've gone
shooting with and I'm sure that they're
all very very uh responsible gun owners
but there are some where I get a sense
true or not
that they almost want
a kinetic
uh incident to occur that does almost
like a yearning for it like a lean in
desire for there to be a reason to put
these skills finally to use
yeah I think that's spot on and it's
scary I mean but at the same time I
understand it because I understand men
you know there's there's a fighting
spirit in all men in most men and and
that outlet is limited when you don't
have conflict when you don't grow up and
allocating that energy in the right
place uh it's why fighting it's why
virtue signaling it's why military
veterans like me and Andy Stumpf and
Sean Ryan are very popular it's because
we live that life in the global war on
terror and we're able to fight and we
have those experiences but what do you
do when you're a 14 year old American
Boy growing up today and there's no
conflict there's no nothing to fight for
and where you divert that energy and
your persona becomes 2A I mean 2A is not
just like uh yeah I'm I'm All About The
Second Amendment it's like that's my
identity and so I remember being a young
Staff Sergeant Green Beret and thinking
man
um I'm judged by my peers because they
don't know if I have the capability of
taking out a bad guy and and in that
culture if you never killed a bad guy
then you're really Nobody Until you
cross that threshold it's like I could
trust this guy now I know he's capable
and you've earned your stripes in some
regard yeah you've earned your stripes
and you're a warrior now that could be
trusted well I I'm afraid that's
happening a lot and I see it it's tragic
Kyle Rittenhouse in that whole
circumstance is a prime example where
people were like yes and then the
comments are egregious it's like this is
a very tragic circumstance altogether
for both Kyle Rittenhouse
[Music]
yes
what you're saying there with with the
Kyle thing is that
um there were
people who felt righteous support
um for a vigilante that was able to do
the thing that they hadn't had the
opportunity to do yes exactly and in
it's part of the culture but me and
Jocko were just recently talking about
this it's like a lot of these guys they
want the fight they think they want the
fight yeah but it's like do they really
want the fight well what another one of
my friends Justin who lives out here I
like terrifyingly competent I've seen
this guy and he's not got a military
background but he just takes his
shooting incredibly seriously this guy's
so competent with all manner of
different weapons all sorts of different
platforms and um I brought this up to
him this sort of uh how would you say
like myth of vigilantism or this leaning
desire for for a kinetic encounter and
um he said that as he's gone further
through his training he's actually
become more and more reticent about
using his firearm because in his words
he was like I know
that there is a very very high
likelihood that if I ever do pull the
trigger with the gun pointed at somebody
it's the last time I'm ever going to
touch a gun in my life
yeah that's a very good case yeah and
and think about the legal ramifications
the moral uh ramifications that you live
with for the rest of your life I mean I
know guys who have actually used their
gun in America in self-defense and the
story isn't about the incident that took
place they're not virtually signaling
the incident they're talking about all
the drama that took place post the
shooting that had to do with the legal
uh system had to do with
um whether or not they were going to be
free or be in prison for the rest of
lives the amount of stress that it
caused in their lives it's like guys you
don't want that like the best way
um
to be on the up and up to be a protector
and a Defender is avoid conflict in the
first place I mean that that's just a
you know it's an old martial art Mantra
if you had the skill sets good for you
but it's a last resort is that you is
that when you go into a restaurant are
you always sat in a table in the corner
with the chair facing the walls so
you've got the broadest range of you is
that still something that's embedded in
you it is I I don't think I could ever
get away from that and you know I've
talked to a lot of my peers growing up
in the military and we all have that
mentality and it's about security it's
not an inconvenience for me it's it's
honestly it would be more of an issue if
I wasn't able to do that because I would
be thinking about it otherwise like you
know it just happened recently I go out
with my girlfriend we're hanging out at
dinner my back is exposed and I said hey
can we just swap chairs and for her it's
not a big deal she knows who I am but
that's ingrained in me as a protector
and as a Defender because I want the
Tactical Advantage I want to be on the
offensive always and that helps me
mitigate risk because if I see this
situation unfolding I can get my family
off the X and and with having children
and people around me that I love I don't
want confrontation I mean I think Jocko
said it uh you know it's like run away
and and run away as fast as you can
because there's no ego and there's
nothing good going to happen in that
kind of conflict in the country it's
nothing good of that is going to happen
so do your best to avoid conflict let me
give you this one man I've never told
this story on the podcast before but
this is a this is about Jocko so I have
Jocko on the show around about a year
ago and I fly out to San Diego to go and
see him and um we sit down and we have
this really interesting conversation
running for like two and a half hours
and you know he's
big scary man that's killed people like
you know he's intimidating dude to sit
across from but it was it was I really
enjoyed it and one of the guys that we
had as a part of the film crew was on
the super tight angle so if people go
back and watch this episode with Jocko
they'll see that there's this really
really tight up super super tight crop
it's almost just his forehead and and
eyes so there was a guy very closely
watching what Jocko was doing with his
eyes for two and a half hours right wow
and as he
as we finished up and we were packing up
he came over and he said dude do you see
what you see what Joker was doing with
his eyes throughout that podcast it's
like
no what do you mean he said well when he
was sitting back and you had your hand
off the desk his eyes were looking in
your face
but as soon as you lean forward and you
put your hand on the side of your laptop
around about every five to ten seconds
or so for just a split second his eyes
would just Dart down and look at where
your hands were
every 10 seconds they would Dart down
and I was like I was sat
70 centimeters away from this guy
and I didn't see it
but the dude that was looking through
the camera only looking at his eyes was
able to detect it
and that that just really made me think
like there are levels to situational
awareness that people who have been in
extended periods of active combat with
really really bad bad actors have got
incredibly acclimatized too
yeah it's it's so fascinating I mean we
talked about it in depth recently and
and he was talking about taking his walk
and his family and down the road and
he's looking for you know last covered
in concealed positions and uh you know
he's looking at the planter pots and
thinking hey can I hide behind that in
the middle of a gunfight while they're
like walking down the sidewalk going to
get ice cream yeah but but it's it's
often a very deliberate trait that
becomes so ingrained it becomes habit
you know I I took a lot of Behavioral
Dynamics courses executive communication
a lot of these courses that taught me
about uh deliberate observation and now
it's a part of my pattern in a routine
and what he was doing was assessing
hands because it's that called a foot
gun it's a handgun right it's that's
where the threat comes from but also
demeanor but hands from somebody who's
uh
sound tactically and has a lot of
experience they they don't give you the
demeanor hits there is no demeanor right
most operators who operate very well you
don't get demeanor hits but their hands
will be doing the deed so hands demeanor
is the constant Vigilant scroll that
we're taking in the information and I
find myself constantly doing that and
quickly assessing it where it can't even
be recognized and it's it's a very cool
story because
um you would only know it if you dialing
it in and you could see the rapid eye
movement and tracking the hands which I
think is fascinating yeah so good man
um talk to me about demeanor I know you
talk about peacocking and how demeanor
can both be uh almost a
um an offensive or a warning tactic
where it can cause you can act in a
manner that disincentivizes people from
doing things what's the what is that
know about demeanor yeah I think
demeanor on the offensive and defensive
side is important to understand first of
all
um you know we say like EDC is important
everyday carry is important because
those are your tools but what's more
important and in your EDC than your
pistol and your waistband is your
posture right because on on the
offensive side your posture your eye
contact being clear and concise with
communication breeds confidence and when
interviewed you know criminals when
interviewed said disc organized people
were typically the most exploitable it's
the it's the uh criminals went after
that the most and so if you're
disheveled if you're disorganized if you
look chaotic you look exploitable you
look weak and so
um in demeanor when we're assessing
Demeter it's basic body language but
sometimes that takes
um an understanding of how to assess
people in different environments so I I
call it spy in the pattern you don't
have to individually assess hands
demeanor hands demeanor hands demeanor
you could look across the entire
spectrum of a restaurant and assess
audibly visually
is there any anomalies is there any
spikes in the pattern is the person
yelling in the booth in the back corner
well that's an anomaly what's typical is
when we identify specific demeanor that
we recognize as a trait that's going to
de-evolve to go bad we kind of write it
off I mean that's our way of being lazy
we just write it off we say oh that's
not a big deal they're just arguing but
what if the person's poking the other
person in the chest well that's about to
be a physical confrontation and then
whether person is putting their hand on
the backstrap of a pistol in their
waistband well you're about to be caught
in the crossfire
because you have a plan to identify
because naturally we do I mean your
vagus nerve is good at identifying
environmental factors that control your
physiological profile it's like hey what
are we going to do activate the nervous
system but what do you want to do post
that experience it's fascinating I just
watched on I'm I'm big into YouTube
um I watch your stuff on on YouTube and
I watch uh all my favorite people on
YouTube and I get I go down rabbit holes
when it comes to central nervous system
kind of stuff and I found this uh video
um these different guys do it there's a
guy like Texas Bushman or something like
that and he hides in a planter
um and and I believe it's been near
Jocko's house if he hikes house he's
he'll get he'll get head-butted
um but he acts like a plant and he acts
like a bush and he's wearing like a
ghillie suit with foliage and when
people walk by he stands up and almost
everybody
has a reaction and that's their vagus
nerve telling their body to react you
know they're being hyper aroused from a
very you know Baseline rest and digest
phase when they respond most of them
respond and they start giggling and
laughing because they realize oh yeah
it's not that big of a deal what I tell
people is identify the spike in the
pattern be prepared to be Flinch
response as Tony blauer would say but
then have a plan of action with that
information you know uh people were
upstairs and they hear a noise
downstairs they don't react to it they
don't respond to it it's like why well
it's because they're lazy like things
aren't happening creating noises as
apparitions it's like something's
causing that get off your butt and go
investigate so when you see somebody's
demeanor
think action like hey that dude didn't
have good demeanor like the way he
looked at me the way that he uh
physically postured on me I don't like
that and a lot of those indications and
behavior getting ahead on the offensive
side will allow you to immediately
respond or react on the reactive side
you know we say uh reaction is always
slower than action not if you have a
heads up display and are being
situationally aware when you identify
those things have a plan of action and
you'll be ahead of it I think Behavior
um I think
um demeanor hits are very important
because it's just it's a deliberate way
to assess our environment where
otherwise we normally just be completely
oblivious to everything that's in our
environment I suppose this offsets this
lack of situational awareness that is
pretty pervasive at the moment you
mentioned everybody's distracted by
their phones etc etc but if it's just a
little bit of a cue every so often just
remember to put your head up to look
around got another story so one of my
friends was in a bar in Tokyo and this
is a a long while ago now and he told me
the story he
he ascribed it to almost like some
astral sixth sense that he's got but I
think he would probably claim that this
guy just has very very high inbuilt
situational awareness and he is able or
has in the past just noticed when
something's going to go wrong so anyway
they were sat at this bar in Japan and
you may have seen these sorts of um bars
before I think they're quite popular in
Asia where the
um floor is all at one level the table
is at the height of the floor and then
the floor sinks in and you almost sit on
the floor with your feet descending
further below the floor and this is this
sort of cool style of bar that he was at
in Japan so anyways there with his wife
who knows him and knows the way that he
acts and knows that he has this sort of
heightened situational awareness astral
realm skill whatever it is and he's got
two friends another couple are with him
and he was sat facing the bar this long
bar relatively busy evening time some
venue somewhere
and he just
something felt off little spidey sense
tingle wasn't sure what it was
and he gave it a couple of seconds and
then he said to his wife
we need to get under the table
and his wife immediately said okay but
the two people that were with him they
didn't know that this guy has this
particular insight and that he tends to
be right more times than he's wrong they
said we're not getting into the table
and he's like I'm telling you when I say
get under the table we need to get under
the table sure enough he convinces them
and they get under the table a couple of
seconds later literally five seconds
after that happens this guy pulls out an
automatic uh rifle and Fires at the bar
nobody gets killed but it turned out
that it was some Gangland uh dispute
between two different groups of people
and this guy had sprayed the room with
an automatic weapon and then fled and it
was all this big thing went on and
obviously everyone else has got their
hands in the air Meanwhile my friend his
wife and the couple that they were with
are literally below the ground and they
were there five seconds before
wow yeah I think that intuition
is the vagus nerve taking in all the
data points of information including
pressure I think you know it's not often
talked about but pressure environmental
pressure uh from human beings which is
they're raised sense of awareness and
you know whether it's cortisol or
adrenaline that spike in elevation
creates pressures on other people where
you sense that I mean people around you
moving through a crowd it is it's a wave
of energy and when you feel that that
intuition to respond and react is what
saves you I mean it's like you know I I
feel that pressure I'm going to stop
right here and then you know the the
brown bear bypasses you because all that
energy is in the air and I think that's
important to note because we all have a
sixth sense we all have that intuition
and it's based on our experiences and
based on our our situational awareness
I'll message Jim I'll tell him that he
should have gone and been a Navy sealer
a CIA contractor
um okay you mentioned earlier on about
that we hear a noise downstairs
Etc it is you know the apart from I
guess active Shooters and mass Shooters
now because of how much attention
they've been given by the Press but I
would say that home invasions are
probably the you know the long-standing
fundamental fear that a lot of people
have
what should people be thinking about
when it comes to fortifying their home
when it comes to preparing for this and
then if they do hear something or if
there is some sort of an incident moving
through that scenario
yeah it's a very interesting question I
mean I I just taught a course this week
in in personal security all women's and
when the ladies asked me
um hey is it appropriate and
self-defense to Rack a shotgun
and I said well what's the circumstance
she said well if somebody comes in the
house and then our racket do I mitigate
risk I said certainly you do but if
you're racking a shotgun which is how
you cycle the operation or chamber
around in a shotgun you're using the
wrong shotgun because the gun should
already be loaded there should be one in
the chamber and you should use a
semi-automatic shotgun but sure do what
you can but if you're racking a shotgun
when somebody's already in your home
you've already made several mistakes one
of his one his one solution that you
could think of you could have a shotgun
that's only for racking and then you
could have a semi-automatic one that you
actually use for shooting so one it
doesn't even need to have a round in or
you could just have dummy rounds in so
you could just rack it and that's the
deterrent and then you can actually pick
the other one up and go downstairs you
could likely go on YouTube and get a
racked shotgun oh yeah I even have the
gun well I didn't even need the gun
anymore get on your phone Bluetooth it
to the speaker downstairs and just so
nice play my shotgun playlist
oh you could do AKs you could do
shotguns you could do it all this This
Woman's so armed
this is clean up here
I just heard a bazooka rack yeah yeah
um you know I I think a lot of people
again think about worst case scenarios
and they think about the last moment
where it's too late you know
preemptively what we're talking about is
physical security you know it's a it's
the idea of like the immigration across
the border wall it's like if there's no
wall then people porously will pour
through the open terrain it's like the
first rule of physical security is
obstacles and Gates and fences Etc so I
always think well how many obstacles are
between me and the potential risk so if
you have a door is the door locked
um if you have a door and it's locked do
you have a deeply recessed bolt latch or
Locking System do you have a chain
across it do you have a bar across it do
you have a storm door do you have a cage
door all the things do you have a thorny
Bush at the base of the window you know
all of these obstacles are going to
benefit you to reduce your chances
having to wrecked the shotgun last
minute and I think most importantly is
technical security I mean I have my cell
phone sitting next to me at all times
because I'm in my studio in my basement
in my house but I have a Vivint Security
system that is Tethered to
um a whole bunch of infrared sensors
that when that kicks the sensor I get an
SMS text message in my home that's
linked to starlink so even if the power
goes down I have the ability to plug
that into a battery power
um a generator and still have mobile
security on site that tells me of the
risk before the risk comes into my home
so I think it's an important
conversation because home defense is is
can create a lot of paranoia and
fear-mongering around the idea but the
last ditch effort in self-defense is
obviously Defending Your Life and you
know we've been criticized before like
um somebody said well
um you would always go down and assess
the threat and I said what do you mean
like well you always you should always
offensively go after the threat that's
in your home I said why would you do
that like why wouldn't you do that like
I have kids so why would I offensively
try to go downstairs and find the threat
that potentially could be setting up to
Ambush me when I could put my kids in a
safe room Back Against The Wall a couple
thresholds deep and Ambush the threat
that's coming towards me so we have to
think about these complexities and go
through them depending on the person
their house and the setup it's all
important in home defense what about
dogs do you need to call Mike ritland
should everyone should everyone have
Mike Redland on on speed dial
I have look before I I uh talked to
Ritalin about this you know Mike's uh a
dog trainer he has Belgian Malinois he
did it in the Navy as a seal uh he does
it as a civilian now a great dude but
he'll advocate for that and I have a
Belgian Malinois long-haired she's a
puppy dog she won't attack anybody but
she certainly will bark as an early
warning and that mitigates risk I know
the decibel range and the velocity
veracity of her bark and I could tell oh
it's it's she's barking because she's
playing or she's barking and somebody is
close to her based on the tempo of her
bark and and that's that's what they're
designed to do by the way I mean dogs do
that inherently is you know genetically
most do
um and that's a good way to mitigate
risks in your home what is it about
those Belgian dogs what what's what's so
special about them what were they bred
for uh you know Belgian Malinois are
really bred for police work they're they
have good noses but they have good
stinks um they're also very agile I mean
I had a Belgian Malinois saved my life
in combat and he paid no way what
happened yeah uh I was in Iraq in 2007
and uh we had 13 foreign Fighters that
were Libyan foreign Fighters real
aggressive foreign Fighters that were
trained
um most of them rigged with suicide vest
and when we got on target we were
already compromised they already knew we
were there so hellacious gun battle uh
grenades uh a gunfight
and at the very tail end of it we were
doing uh what's called a BDA a battle
damage assessment and going across the
objective moving to a limit of Advance
like we sweep across the objective and
we kill any bad guys that are
potentially alive and fighting and as we
are sweeping across we came across a a
bad guy that was in the Reeds we
couldn't see them with our night vision
goggles but the aircraft above us with
their thermal infrared sensors could see
the heat signature and so they
identified them we backed up me and
another guy named Rob that was next to
me
um the dog handler Rick came up behind
us and we took the dog
went out on the um about 15 yards in
front of us and we thought the guys all
the guys that we had been in gunfights
were dead
this guy was still alive Vinnie our dog
bit him
um he shot one round we heard one round
and then he detonated uh a grenade or an
explosive vest and when that happened it
killed Vinnie instantly but it saved me
and the other guy's life life because of
their sacrifice so they're real good at
what they do
um my dog actually comes from a line of
police dogs and military dogs and they
have good instincts but they're also
very loyal and they're good with
families so a dog could be your first
line of defense especially uh in a
smaller apartment condo or whatever you
got where you don't have a lot of
obstacles before the bad guy gets into
your door
what's your
um
or what should people consider when
they're thinking about handguns in the
home or any any kind of gun in the home
I know that I don't know this is
preparedness but it's the error that we
hear about now of accidental discharge
of you know people carrying Israeli etc
etc like what's your what's your
thoughts on this yeah my thoughts have
changed since I had kids my my son I
have twins a boy and a girl and they're
four but very capable as you know they
could pick up a firearm and they
understand what it is you know they they
see Daddy's firearms that are
deliberately positioned throughout the
house that are unloaded because I want
to inoculate my kids to seeing them
around and not being like I was as a
child when my father was in the military
and in law enforcement
being enthralled by this thing that was
always hidden and tucked in a drawer and
we know kids they're always going to
find the thing that's in the drawer
because curiosity and so
one thing to think about is having
mocked boxes that are capable of
Biometrics keypads uh turn combinations
whatever it may be where you have the
gun at ready access but it takes a
locking mechanism as a barrier to
protect the kids that are in your home I
also have a tactic where I separate the
the gun from the ammunition right and so
if I have the ammunition and it's staged
out of sight out of sound
they don't make that connection at least
not now as four-year-old children but
you know I have a protocol where I'll
pick up the pistol I'll attach the
magazine and then I'll go looking for
what assessing what the problem is I
also recommend and especially in home
defense I mean I I think we should be
looking at this across the board that
you have suppressed guns and you know
suppressors unlike the Hollywood
examples of silencing the pistol or the
rifle don't do that they just reduce the
decibel ranges that would be important
because if you're conditioned for stress
if you train a lot you certainly will
not have auditory exclusion you'll be
deaf when you're in that gunfight and we
don't wear peltors on our heads or air
protection like we do on the Range but
also you don't want to shoot a firearm
in the proximity of your children and
put them in fight or flight where
they're in the fetal position and
they're screaming and shock or their
hands are over their ears and you can't
even get them to move so I I think about
these things as a tactical Advantage
like somebody said why would you ever
have a gun with a suppressor with a
light in your home that's silly just use
a regular pistol and I'm like well
certainly but I want to win you could
lose but I'm going to win and if the
difference is a suppressor on my gun
with a light that gives me the Tactical
advantage that costs an extra few
hundred dollars why would I not do that
so I'm always looking for the Tactical
event what about reducing uh round carry
or velocity you know if you're in a
house I look at some of these houses
that are being built near me in Texas
you guys have interesting large houses
over here but they are made out of
wood and polystyrene you know I
I look at every home I have a bunch of
real estate in the UK and it's like Rock
Solid 1910 1920s brick hard heavy cold
and hot
and I I don't even I mean a Nerf round
would probably go through most most
American Homes but I imagine this is
something that you consider if you are
going to get into you know some kinetic
allocation with somebody
what about the kids that are in the room
next door what about the people that
live in the house across the street from
you what about whatever whatever is that
something that you consider oh
absolutely I mean it's very important to
consider in a way I mean like you said
most houses have generic cork board
which is plywood that just you know that
round at 1300 feet per second Hollow
um uh limited penetration or Full Metal
Jacket it doesn't matter at that speed
velocity in foot pounds of energy it's
going to penetrate that wall depending
on proximity and so what I tell people
is one the most important thing as a
rule of firearm safety is know your
Target and what's beyond it right uh
it's a game of angles there are
self-defense rounds that limit
penetration create vertical displacement
of energy which is very important
keeping the round intact to reduce the
over penetration that we see going
through human bodies but also obstacles
which is very important in some cases
depending on our understanding of our
environment we would want to penetrate
the obstacle like when I was in the
military I carried 62 grain grain tip
which had a still core penetrator
because I mean green tip comes from at
least 62 Grand green tip comes from the
requirement to shoot
um small steel pot helmets this is
Russian era ammo
the reason we have that and we would
carry it is because if we ran into
Vehicles we need something potentially
to create
um penetration in those obstacles of
those Vehicles so sometimes you want to
penetrate the office would you ever be
able to get some enemy assailant through
a wall with something like that as well
yeah and I tell people I tell people
think about it this way when you train
on a flat range and you're shooting
paper still do you train with obstacles
typically you don't but how many bad
guys do you know that would just stand
in the open holding the gun like this or
holding the gun like this and wait to be
shot they're going to naturally find and
seek obstacles they're going to go into
their bathroom and shut the door behind
them do you have the ability to affect
them now standard holocore doors
standard plywood uh you're going to be
able to penetrate it no matter what but
I have a St I have a a solid oak door as
my front door now if somebody was trying
to get through my door well what weapon
would I use you'd have a tough time at
least
affecting them on the other side of that
with a nine mil pistol from distance but
if I had a 308 if I had a 556 that had
the ability to penetrate potentially I
could affect them all these things need
to be weighed and considered especially
inside the home where it's most
dangerous and most likely that you're
you hear the noise you're running to
defend your children potentially or your
family potentially and you need to be
thinking about those
yeah it's the
lack of applicability from range to
environment is something that I've
really started to learn a lot more over
the last year you know since not really
firing again except Beyond tourist
in Vegas and all the rest of it that you
do normally when you go on Bachelor
parties to now spending a lot of time
with guys that are incredibly heavily
armed and Incredibly proficient some of
the guys are whatever it is Grand
wizards of the competitive shooting
there's a couple of guys here that do
um Atomic Legion that uh it's like a
competitive shooting uh
Community out here and um
I was with Tucker Max who you may or may
not know the guy that ownscribe media
big into preparedness as well I'm sure
he'll be a fan of yours and um we were
at his house but I think I'd turned up
late or we'd maybe gone for lunch or
something so he was shooting at a time
that he wasn't used to shooting at and
we were shooting with a red dot and I
was I'd lined everything up and we were
just practicing it's those hostage
um uh targets so for the people that
don't know there's like a hole in the
chest and then when you hit the hole in
the chest the target appears over the
shoulder of the same body so that you
move from person to over the top of
person so that it teaches you to be able
to move from the target to somebody that
would be almost behind the Target and
I'm like lining the shot up from not too
far away and he's like dude you are
Miles off this so I'm is this gun dialed
in or whatever and he picked it up we
didn't realize that when the sun is low
and entering a red dot Target it creates
two dots
it creates a second Dot and it's not as
bright but if you were in a rush and you
just pulled the gun up you would be
firing and you're like
10 degrees away from where you should be
and he realized you know this is a guy
that's thought very very long and hard
about all of the different ways that
this could happen and this could happen
and this could happen and even he as
somebody that spent all of this time had
never had his Red Dot facing the Sun at
this particular time of night because
we'd gone for lunch
and he thought oh like this is
another new piece of information that I
wouldn't have picked up on the Range if
I'd always just been shooting in the
same direction
yeah that's those Lessons Learned are so
important I mean we used a term lights
up sites up you know just the the the
small tactics we use depending on where
the light is if it's over your back if
it's on your sites versus it's going
down you might have to hold completely
different I I think one of the Fatal
flaws in training period is most people
don't train low light no light and 60
plus percent of shootings take place at
night or in low light you know most
mostly we have ambient light in and
around us but how many people train at
night really Nobody Does that we offer
No Light low light courses so does
sheepdog response uh good training
institutions do that but how many US are
willing to train in those conditions but
are always caring in those conditions
and and understand the statistical
probability I I like hearing stories
like that because you know anybody in
the Tactical space
that sits on a platform on a pedestal
and says this is the end-all be-all
solution it's not the right person to
learn from I mean there should always be
room for adaptation and growth bad guys
certainly adapt certainly grow and
evolve so should you and it's an open
form for discussion these kind of things
like like you just mentioned should be
talked about should be educated across
the platform and that's the kind of
industry that we need for us all to grow
together
Mike Glover ladies and gentlemen Mike
let's bring this one home why should
people go if they want to find out more
about you and the book and all the work
that you do and how they can protect
themselves yeah philcaster rival.com
everywhere that books are found Amazon
your local bookstore
um my channels mainly are on YouTube at
Mike Glover actual on my YouTube channel
and then my Instagram is mike.a.glover
Mike I appreciate you I'm looking
forward to catching up and eating some
more food next time to eat through Texas
I can't wait brother thank you man if
you enjoyed that episode then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe